et fin de la manif des lycéens paris cet
après-midi demandent le passage du bac
et des bts en contrôle continu
une revendication rejetée par le
ministre de l'éducation
les élèves dénoncent les conditions dans
laquelle s'est passé cette année
scolaire entre coupé par les compliments
et des courants distance hier je pense
que un aménagement du bac voire une
animation des épreuves seraient
bénéfiques
or ce qui est mieux qu'une annulation
c'est justement la solution qui a été
trouvée
n'ayez pas pour toutes les épreuves de
choisir la meilleure note entre la note
des épreuves et celle de la moyenne de
l'année ce qui peut être une solution
mais beaucoup de gens n'ont pas été
préparés aux épreuves donc les maintenir
tel quel avec aussi peu de changements
c'est quand même assez fou finalement
c'est toujours parce qu'on doit passer
c'est quand même dans un mois le
gouvernement a toujours pas pris
d'initiative clair donc on est venu
exprimer notre désaccord dans la rue là
ça bloque les lycées de fuir moment et
pour l'instant on n'a toujours pas de
réponse
après plus d'un an de pandémie on a
toujours en fait des conditions
d'enseignement qui ne sont absolument
pas favorable à la préparation au bac
dans de bonnes conditions et de mélanger
nallo conditions d'études par exemple on
a pas mal de l'essaim qui n'ont pas
passé le bac blanc personnellement je
suis en section d'investissement
international donc on a encore deux
épreuves en fait à passer
deux épreuves de quatre heures écrite et
de zorro on n'est pas du tout prêt c'est
des coefficients 15 chacune dont
coefficient 30 au total donc comme les
spécialités qui ont été annulés mais
celles ci sont maintenus on est oubliés
on n'est même pas écouté dans les
annonces on n'est même pas mentionné
alors qu'on est quand même plus de 50
section en france